en parlant de filles prof qui est à des
climats je vous aimais beaucoup solaire
oui mais je crois qu'il faut partir tout
de suite d'un livre qui est très célèbre
qu'on peut trouver des petits qui
s'appelle alors oui voilà pendant comme
au commencement pourtant ils sont
complexes
moi je vois qu'il ya deux deux livres
essentiels pour la littérature de la
deuxième moitié du xxème siècle aux
etats-unis c'est lolita et ce livre-ci
portnoy et son complexe
je crois que c'est les deux livres qui
ont fait le plus à la fois le plus grand
scandale le plus grand choc révélant de
deux continents complètement inconnu
l'invention de la nymphette par nabokov
est ce ce livre qui est paru en 69 il ya
donc 20 ans d'être là qui a et qui avait
eu un succès considérable il a été vendu
à cinq millions d'exemplaires dans le
monde entier et ses portes non ils sont
compliqués d'habitude quand on parle de
philip roth maintenant tout le monde
pense à portnoy et son complexe il est
complète il a été complètement happé par
ce biais les valeurs ce qui fait que il
écrit depuis 20 ans une oeuvre très
considéré avec des livres que je
considère moi comme des shaders qui ont
tendance à être désormais pas lu ou pas
apprécié tellement par la critique parce
que ce livre a eu tellement de succès
qu'on lui faire en quelques sortes payer
cette explosion or à mon avis il est en
train de construire une oeuvre nous
allons voir ça avec la contrôler leur
revenait maintenant ils sont complexes
il faut peut-être dire de quoi il s'agit
je vous dis voilà portelli son complexe
qu'est ce que c'est que le complexe de
portnoy c'est un trouble lit mais sans
en exergue un trouble caractérisé par un
perpétuel conflit entre deux vivent
pulsions d'ordre éthique et altruiste et
d'irrésistibles exigences sexuelles
souvent de tendances perverses
voici ce qu'en dit spilborghs hull phil
bogle celle analystes supposaient il ya
beaucoup il est beaucoup question de
piste de la position psychanalytique
chez roth c'est ça qui est introduit à
mon avis une dimension complètement
nouvelle avec la littérature érotique
alors voilà voilà ce que ça donne
exhibitionnisme voyeurisme fétichisme
auto érotisme et fellation s'ils
manifestent à profusion par suite de
l'intervention du suroît du sujet
toutefois ni ses fantasmes lycée
attenant genre de réelles satisfactions
d'ordre sexuel mais plutôt à
l'insurmontable sentiment de long
et la peur du châtiment en particulier
sous forme de castration c'est un
article de schille vos gueules qui
s'appelle le pénis est perdu voilà donc
ça c'est de cesser le chef-d'oeuvre de
rohff et de quoi s'agit-il
c'est pourquoi ce livre a eu un tel un
tel retentissement ce qu'il raconte
au fond le ce qui se passe dans une
éducation deux agneaux warraq donc dans
un milieu de d'immigrants juifs
américains
et qu'est ce que ça donne comme produit
tout à fait explosive c'est à dire que
bon euro il ya le gala mère absolument
dévorante de la mère et la mère juive la
blague il ya tout un il ya tout un
vocabulaire gueddiche à la fin je crois
qu'on va faire entrer le gi joe en
littérature comme comme jamais avant lui
en fait une façon tout à fait
scandaleuse c'est bien petit glossaire
yiddish à la fin qui est merveilleux
parisot dénonçant pas les mêmes par
exemple le flanc ou ça veut dire un
pénis ou super ça veut dire baiser oui
mais qu'est ce qui se passe la mer et
dévorante d'amour le père et humilié
mais est constipé
et ce garçon pouvait par ses parents
découvrent le son sexe et de le fait que
sa seule division
sa seule liberté c'est sont celles dont
la branlette comme ils disent très bien
le premier chapitre de la branlette et
les expériences de masturbation chez lui
c'est à dire dans l'appartement
c'est à dire la lutte pour les toilettes
pour être seul dans les toilettes
pouvoir acculé tranquillement dans les
toilettes
ensuite tous les fantasmes qui sont
associés à la masturbation
par exemple la scène fameuse qu'à faire
un scandale énorme comme quand ils se
masturbent dans le foie qui dans le
frigidaire de ses parents un morceau de
foie ou alors ensuite petit à petit et
de fil en aiguille cette masturbation
accéléré monumental l'entraînent à
l'heure après salle à la poursuite des
filles qui ne sont pas juifs qui
s'appelle les chics song il y joue pas
c'est cette obsession des dd non juives
alors là il ya une série de personnages
tout à fait étonnant de femmes avec une
l humour une dérision constante dans le
temps elle râle c'est qu'il va faire
scandale
mais un peu partout mais surtout dans la
communauté juive absolument il ay là il
a entraîné une réprobation la
reconstitution considérables dit tiens
il en a et à leurs riffs lewis est
justement il en a beaucoup souffert
il ya eu des articles très assez vifs
contre lui rien de comparable à
l'affairé jeudi puisque jeudi à parler
de philippe aurensan dix ans mais on se
compare en route mais enfin il ya
absolument les deux les deux situations
sont absolument pas comparable n'a pas
été condamné à mort et personne n'a
essayé de le tuer mais en fait il ya eu
des articles quand même très violent
parce qu'il a choqué de plein fouet
l'image idéale de des juifs pour
eux-mêmes et c'était cette espèce de
d'idéalisation ce qui va appeler
maintenant la contredit appelle la
pastorale à leur façon à la con tre vie
parce que oui alors victoire donc pour
tous comment est ce que réussit à
survivre à ce portail si scandaleux il a
inventé un double qui s'appelle nathan
zuckerman et il ya une série de livres
très merveilleux bon je passe il ya
professeur jean y en a plein le
oui ça c'est zoug et le lecteur le
lecteur doit aller tout de suite aux
deux derniers c'est à dire la leçon
d'anatomie
c'est à dire est étonnant et le l'a
contredit quant à nice et là j'ai pas
mal professeur de désir professeurs des
magnifiques le saint laurent
le saint est grave et il a été
énormément de très très très bon livre
mois pour moi c'est le plus grand
écrivain vivant vraiment et donc ce
superman qui est le double de portnoy et
raconte comment il survit à cette
affaire à ce scandale à cette
réprobation profonde qu'il a entraînée
et on sent qu'il n'est nulle part
nulle part chez lui c'est à dire petit à
petit elle dans ce déracinement dans
cette dans ce décalage avec la vie ils
montrent que la vie vraiment d'un
écrivain aujourd'hui c'est à dire
quelqu'un qui ne peut pas croire à
l'authenticité des vies et qui est
obligée sans cesse de raconter pour pour
pour saisir une identité qui le fuit
alors ça c'est un livre m magnifique il
commence par une histoire d'impuissance
c'est un frère c'est son frère le frère
de nathan zuckerman qui tout à coup à
cause d'un maladies cardiaques découvre
qu'il est que sa vie sexuelle ne marche
plus et bien qu'il a des habitudes quand
même
de ce point de vue avec une dentiste il
a une petite assistante avec laquelle il
a l'habitude de faire une fellation tous
les soirs avant de rentrer chez lui avec
une femme les enfants et donc et tout le
problème pour lui est de savoir
continuer s'il s'il doit se faire opérer
pour retrouver sa virilité
c'est magnifique et finit par se repérer
il est mort donc nathan zuckerman
raconte une réponse l'enterrement de son
frère qui est mort donc au champ
d'honneur
mais c'est vrai que ça paraît drôle un
toaster tragique belgique d'autant plus
vraiment l'enterrement la femme la femme
légitime du frère se lève pour dire
voilà je vais expliquer à la communauté
pourquoi mon mari est mort c'est pas
s'ils ne pouvaient plus accomplir son
devoir conjugal nous étions un couple
magnifique star dont premier mensonge
qui s'était passé pour ça du tout
c'était pour la petite assistance avec
qui il avait donc c'est ensuite on
apprend que c'était pas ça le vrai sujet
c'est au contraire c'était c'était une
autre affaire encore cet excès surtout
celle attendue qu'à masquer et et qui a
inventé son frère c'est ce qui est
absolument extraordinaire
pour moi j'ai twist j'ai eu un plaisir
inouï à lire ce livre parce qu'il est
tout le temps sur l'apparence c'est à
dire que nous lecteurs nous croyons lire
quelque chose et plus loin philippe
rozier nous dire mais non c'était autre
chose
d'abord c'était pas henry mais c'est
nathan s'agissait on croyait suivre une
femme sonia et c'est une heure de grande
écoute à l'autre tandis que c'est
éblouissant toutes les techniques sont
un moment de révélation qui l'a devant
l'école dans le quartier orthodoxe de
jérusalem où je crois qu'il est une
révélation müller il n'y aurait plus
passer ça participe depuis un jour que
je crois qu'un ensemble breton rang et
dans des trucs mais pour un écrivain
très succinct trouve que c'est très sûr
à axer ma vie d'homme
le jeu déroule à la fin enfin face et
c'est tout à fait pire ont des liens
c'est beau si tu remarqué quelque chose
entier puis ce qui est vrai et ce qui ne
l'est pas et les personnages alors
terminale ont là dessus mais bon
pourquoi faut-il lire ce livre m'a parce
que c'est le meilleur et camions s'est
tout de même dit henry et au fond c'est
un plaisir continue et il répond ah ben
ça m'étonne je m'étonne que ce livre
soit pas en tête des best-sellers tout
de suite alors que d'autres livres
américains leçon il n'y a pas de
comparaison c'est le plus grand il faut
le dire et le répéter il faut que tout
le monde
il se dit assez bien non les vertiges
public je craque c'est l'écrivain qu'il
fait peur parce qu'il n'est pas pour
l'authenticité toute sa ruse comme
nabokov toute sa ruse tout surtout son
plaidoyer et tout son travail et pour
montrer l'inauthenticité des conduites
humaines c'est à dire que les gens se
raconte des histoires dans leur vie ils
ne sont pas vraies et ils essayent de
faire leur vie par rapport à des
histoires qui se racontent toujours la
pastorale de la rédemption
ils veulent avoir une vie il est à
leicester donc il est c'est vraiment mon
avis ça c'est la quintessence de
l'écrivain secteur car il n'y a pas de
l'authenticité de la vie humaine il faut
se déprécier
[Musique]